John it's so wonderful to see you I saw
you last week for the listening session
and it was a surreal experience because
we had people all around the world come
together to listen to your seventh album
bring your love it was so beautiful what
does it mean for you to be able to put
up music right now that people can
actually feel some joy oh you know I've
been getting that message from so many
people right now album is bringing them
joy and you know this spring has been
really tough for people all around the
world but particularly here in the
United States we've seen a crisis after
crisis and people are stressed and
people are concerned and you know I
think people needed a bit of a musical
pick-me-up and hopefully this album has
been able to provide that for some
people especially when you drop a lot
because when you drop it I was off my
chair dancing it is your favorite isn't
it
I wrote it earlier this year I think it
was January it was the first song I
wrote coming out of vacation you know
we'd been away for the holidays and I
came back and we wrote this song and I
was so excited I was like okay now I
feel like the album is basically done
because now that I have a la it's like
now we're really cooking here and so it
wasn't the last song I wrote for the
album but it was one of the final ones
because once I wrote that I knew that we
had a really strong album and it was
something special I remember walking
around the Grammys knowing that I had
just done these songs and and feeling so
good and feeling like I had a secret I
couldn't tell everyone yet you know
while they were giving out awards for
all the last year's work I was like I've
got some really good stuff here I wish
they knew and now it's finally out it is
and you're talking about being a strong
album it is the fact thing of these
incredible collaborations - I mean
you're bringing back Jenny Aiko you have
coffee a new artist do you make the
effort to make sure you give a platform
to new black
well I love featuring newer artists I
love featuring artists that are
important to our culture and to our
music and I was able to feature one of
our great R&B singers jhene aiko a great
reggae dancehall artist coffee and one
of our great female MCS Rhapsody and I
was really happy to do that because I
felt like one they would make the songs
better they were amazing artists and
they they would sound great on those
particular songs but also I just felt
like it was a great way to bring some
feminine energy to the album you know me
being a guy and you hearing my voice the
whole time I felt like it'd be cool to
hear some female voices and have their
perspective as writers as performers and
just bringing a different energy to the
album and then of course we also have
the great guitar god Gary Clark jr.
representing booze and rock and we're so
happy to have him on the album as well I
think all four featured guests just made
the album so much better and I'm honored
that they graced us with their presence
and you know you have a way with your
music that speaks on so many different
levels from being about love about hope
and I went into this vortex of your
older songs I was into glory I was
listening to wake up the roots from I
think that was 2010 and those songs
resonate with what's happening right now
and a lot of us are feeling this is a
pivotal moment of change for you who has
been an activist what would you consider
change well we want to get closer to
real freedom real justice really quality
and when we have more justice when we
have real equality and when we have a
communities that are healthy and safe
for everyone we'll have more peace as
well and so I think that's what everyone
really wants they want a healthy safe
community that's peaceful and loving and
it takes policy to get us there it takes
changing people's hearts and minds as
well but that's what the goal should be
and that's why we talk about changing
the policing system here in this country
that's why we
talk about ending mass incarceration
because we believe that that will bring
us closer to real justice and real peace
in our communities you know you've been
very vocal you just said it defunding
the police is a big one for you why is
that well I think the word defund scares
a lot of people but what it really is it
what it really means is saying let's
think about our budget let's think about
what our priorities are when our city is
deciding what to spend money on when our
state is deciding what to spend money on
whenever you spend it on one thing
you're precluding yourself from spending
it on another thing because there's a
finite amount of money and we believe
that if we were to invest in things that
are more edifying for the community like
better health care better schools yeah
better drug treatment for people who are
going through drug addiction issues
better mental health treatment for
people who are having mental health
problems a lot of the things that we
consider crime and social problems you'd
be preventing those problems rather than
trying to contain them and police them
with a guy with a badge and a gun so
making those choices to invest in
solutions that will make the community
really healthy and really say means we
wouldn't need to invest as much money in
policing and so that's really what the
defunding pleas movement is all about
you know I'm a mom and I have two girls
you had two kids and I recently they're
older and I just recently had a
conversation about racism mm-hmm your
kids are young what's that conversation
going to be like to teach them how
they're going to be perceived in the
world well first of all I want them to
love themselves for who they are for
their skin color for their the grade of
their hair all the things that make them
special I want them to love that about
themselves and so part of what we have
to do as parents is make sure they know
that they are beautiful and that they're
valued for for who they are but then of
course the world is going to be what the
world is going to be and they have to be
introduced they have to be introduced to
that at some point and we have to have
real conversations about
what that means and and give them some
historical context so they understand
what this stuff is coming from it's not
just out of the blue and then try to
help them cope and and deal with a world
that's not ideal and I don't know that
the world ever will be ideal but we have
to prepare them to deal with it and and
so at some point we're gonna have to
have those conversations but in the
meantime we're just going to try to
educate them help them believe in
themselves as individuals and be proud
of the traditions that they come from
from african-american tradition and the
Thai tradition of their mother and their
mother-in-law and and their grandmother
so you know all of that is meaningful to
them and and hopefully will teach them
to value that and to be proud of it and
then help prepare them for a world
that's less than ideal that's an ideal
you guys are the cutest family you know
that right you guys are the most
adorable family
you're like the Obamas you know there is
someone the silver lining when it comes
to isolation because you get time with
your family like you've never had before
I mean what have you discovered as a
father and I guess as a husband well
we've spent a lot of time together what
I what I do love about my wife and this
quarantine time has kind of highlighted
that for all of us is how creative she
is and how fun she is with coming up
with great ideas for the kids
we've done camping in the backyard she's
planned a wedding for Lunas stuffed
animals it's been we've had both of
their birthdays during the quarantine so
no friends have been able to come over
but we've celebrated them anyway so
she's been spearheading all of that and
she's just really great at that I'm just
lucky that I get to parent with her
because she she's such a good creative
parent and the kids are lucky to have
her and she also surprised me and gave
me a really nice dinner for Father's Day
this weekend so she's really the MVP of
this Corps
and in our house I'm just so happy how
is she doing she had surgery recently
are the kids jumping on her she resting
is she's doing better you know it just
takes a little recovery time because any
time someone's you know cutting you up a
bit you're gonna have some pain and some
recovery time but she's doing a lot
better now bigger lung yes love is
defined in so many different ways in so
many eras it changes the way we feel
about love how would you define love and
2020 well I think part of its the
classic way you think of it you know
it's the interpersonal love you feel for
your partner for your family your close
friends but you know when I think about
love and I talked about it in speeches a
lot whenever if someone asked me to
speak I talked about what love really
should mean to us is more than just
loving the people close to you that's
the easy part it's harder to actually
love your neighbor that lives in your
neighborhood but also your neighbor that
lives across town or across the world
and that doesn't mean you love them the
same way you love your family members
but you see their humanity you value
them you realize that they have family
members that love them
and that gets us closer to what justice
really means is seeing everyone's
humanity seeing that they're valuable
and that they are loved and and creating
policy and practices that that that
really show that they're valued and
loved mmm
John thank you for this album it's the
perfect timing
it makes me feel good it's gonna make
everyone else feel good and thank you
for everything that we do I mean I
really it means a lot to me as a person
and I think it means a lot to a lot of
people out there so thank you thank you
as a pleasure talking to you
you